welcome back to cbs this morning
more than 600 pages of newly unsealed
court documents were released overnight
containing new details about galen
maxwell's relationship with jeffrey
epstein
now they appear to contradict her
version of events about when she last
spoke to him
this month she pleaded not guilty to
being part of his alleged sex
trafficking ring mola lenghi's in
brooklyn outside the federal detention
center where she's being held
moeller good morning to you there are a
lot of contradictions in this case
well yeah gail you know maxwell's
attorneys actually tried to stop these
documents from surfacing even
asking a u.s district court judge to
intervene with a phone call that
judge ultimately denied the request and
accused maxwell
of trying to muddy the waters on her way
to mounting her legal defense
to bring awareness to this weeks after
gallane maxwell was denied release on
bail as she awaits trial she figures
prominently into newly unsealed court
documents
some of which accuse her of facilitating
and participating
in years of abuse against young women as
for maxwell's recent claim that it's
been
more than a decade since she was in
contact with jeffrey epstein
the documents appear to reveal that is
untrue in a january 2015
email exchange with epstein maxwell
wrote she'd appreciate it if a woman
named shelley would come out and say
she had been epstein's girlfriend
epstein responded
okay with me you have done nothing wrong
and i would urge you to start acting
like it
go outside head high not as an escaping
convict
go to parties deal with it now maxwell's
being held in a federal detention
facility and facing up to 35
years in prison it comes after years of
allegations from accusers like virginia
roberts giuffray
who is not one of the alleged victims in
maxwell's case
due frey spoke to gail king earlier this
month you couldn't say no to jeffrey and
england because
yeah you're afraid for your life the
unsealed documents are part of a settled
civil suit between maxwell and jufrey
they include a deposition in which drew
frey claimed she was sent to have sex
with
several high-profile men at epstein and
maxwell's direction
including the owner of a large hotel
chain and
a foreign president who she described as
quote spanish
and in his forties based on the arrest
of yellen maxwell do you think there are
a lot of men
in this country in this world that
should be panicking based on the
information that she has
oh yeah and i really hope they are
very well known popular men that
everyone would know the names of i can't
wait for the day of
truth to light
well maxwell's 2016 deposition is
expected to be released sometime next
week
after a u.s district court judge denied
her request
for that to remain sealed of the
documents that we have seen there are
still
several names that remain redacted which
could be an indication
of the scale of jeffrey epstein's
alleged sex trafficking operation
might still largely be unknown vlad all
right to be continued lanky thank you
very much